Do you coach patients with Parkinson's at your clinic?
I have a friend who's son-in-law only 41 years old was diagnosed with it and I recommended
your clinic.
Told her I would ask about coaching for him.
Yes, it no at different levels.
They certainly wouldn't be a part of this Zoom call.
This is only for cancer patients.
I've had Parkinson's patients in the past.
The right can be extremely helpful for Parkinson's, but the biggest thing is doing antibody testing,
neural antibody testing to find out what is going on with them as far as, do they have
antibodies to neural tissue, they always do, and then how to find the triggers and reduce
the inflammation, so you have to do, there's a lot of labs that are involved with that,
so it's totally, it's a little bit different level of care.
That's one of the reasons, not just Parkinson's, but it's all autoimmune issues and the reason
why I created the chronic disease in autoimmune course.
If they're willing to work through that course and work through understanding and educating
themselves, then by all means, we take on people with different cases.